reliable 20-minute test how much of a
game changer will that be
well being able to expand mass testing
with these
new technologies it is a
huge positive step forward in our battle
against the virus
if you think about it a combination of
everybody doing
social distancing and then testing to
find out where the virus is
is our best way of avoiding having to do
local lockdowns in our best way of
keeping the virus under control
so you know at the moment if you take a
test the swab goes in your
throat it has to go off to the lab we
get most of them back
the next day but changing that to
something where you can
just have some saliva and 20 minutes
later you've got the result
that means we can have many many more
people tested
and also you can just get the result
fast and know that you are covered safe
and how do we access those tests
well we're dealing with about a hundred
different testing companies at the
moment who are
have got new innovative technologies and
when those tests work we're always
putting them through rigorous
trials because obviously the tests have
to work and
we're then rolling them out and that's
one of the things that we're announcing
today
putting half a billion pounds more into
these
innovative new next generation tests and
then
rolling them out in a way that helps
control the virus so for instance in
salford
in greater manchester um we're taking
the testing right into the center of
town
so that everybody can get a test and we
can find out
anybody who is asymptomatic doesn't have
symptoms
but has coronavirus and likewise you can
then start to think about how you can
use this
for much more ways of opening things up
and
getting life back to normal because
people will be able to know quickly
whether or not they've got coronavirus
and therefore have the confidence
knowing that they don't have it if they
get a negative test
to to um to go about more normal life
so once you can access the test it'll
take 20 minutes
how do you access the test is what my
viewers will want to know this morning
yes so the new innovative test that we
are backing today essentially have the
lab
in the back of a van so that can go to
an area where there's a high number of
um where there's an outbreak high number
of cases
and test large numbers of people and
they get the result on the spot there
are
there are other new technologies coming
on where in fact
uh you get the um that could be done but
sent to your home instead
and we're working with those companies
to try to get those
ramped up to scale so that we can
uh so that we can roll them out so all
of this is about taking you know the
as you said in the intro a massive
growth in our testing capabilities
and we've hit all the targets that we
set for the growth of testing
during this coronavirus and
obviously we want to go much further
with mass testing
okay but um as of today if you wanted a
test on the nhs
i put my postcode in and the the website
app and it's 100 miles i have to travel
to have a test that's not satisfactory
is it
that's rubbish in fact well this is one
of the it's one of the reasons that
we're
we're investing so much more in new
testing and these new technologies can
really change that
because at the moment the system the
system works well of course there's
operational challenges from time to time
but it works well
and we're finding a higher and higher
proportion of the people in the country
who have uh coronavirus and getting them
those uh those tests so that they can be
properly looked after
but absolutely you know we need to
we need to roll out more testing we have
done throughout this crisis
and um and and today is another step in
solving some of those
uh the problems with the existing
technology
which has to as i say go off to the lab
and come back and you have to go
to that drive-through center which
sometimes can be a bit of so how long so
how long before i don't have to drive a
hundred miles for a test
uh well we're starting that today
with in in salford and the expansion of
the test
the trials that we've done on this in
southampton and then we're
rolling it out across the country so so
um it
is starting from today in some parts of
the country and then rolling out across
the country
in the weeks and months to come okay
what if i'm coming back through one of
the big airports can i have a test there
well the challenge with quarantine
is that because the virus incubates
for up to two weeks
if people get a test when they get off
the plane
there's only a very small chance that
that will catch
the virus even if they've got it
and the experts tell us the scientist
says that that chance is about seven
percent
and that means that that that's why you
have to quarantine
and i you know i know our quarantine
policy um
caused a few um uh ripples when we
introduced it a few months ago
quite a few people were unhappy with it
but if you've seen what's happened in
america brazil india and now in france
and spain
and other parts of europe the quarantine
policy has protected this country
it does mean that we have to you know
sometimes make some
swift decisions when we reintroduce
quarantine in a country where the case
rate is shooting up
but we do it to protect this country and
i think the quarantine policy has
absolutely proved its worth okay um
should i go to portugal tomorrow or will
i have to quarantine when i come back
well what i'd say is that everybody has
seen that we
are prepared to take decisions to put
individual countries
back on the quarantine list if that's
what
is necessary and we keep this
constantly under review and then we
announce the decisions usually on a on a
friday lunchtime
and so people should look at the data
but also should only travel
if they are prepared to quarantine if
things you know if the
frankly if the virus goes up when
they're
in that country unfortunately we do have
to take these decisions
to keep people here safe no it's not
going to change between
today and tomorrow though is it health
security here's an opportunity for
the government to be ahead of the curve
for my viewers who are potentially going
to portugal tomorrow will they be able
to go without quarantine when they come
back or not simple question
one simple question and the simple
answer is that we follow the data
and we make these announcements in an
organized way on a
on a friday lunch time so you don't know
well that's not true because
when it came to spain it was a saturday
so um it you know it is very fluid
are you saying that you don't yet know
that you don't yet know
well you raised a really good point
about spain which is that the case rate
was shooting up
very very rapidly in spain so we did
have to act very fast
and i'm i'm so glad that we did because
you know the number of cases just
carried on going up in spain it was
really important that we took that
action to keep people here safe
you know and one of the challenges in
this coronavirus for all of us
frankly is that you know the the the inf
the data changes
this virus as you know we only have a
limited amount of time if you could
answer my question
if people are thinking about going to
portugal tomorrow i'm sure you know by
now
should they go or not or do you not yet
know
we're going to publish a further
decision tomorrow having looked at the
data
and i i'm not going to pre-judge that
i'm telling you that there is a you know
the government looks
very carefully at all the data and then
makes these decisions and publishes them
in an organized way and i'm going to
stick to that principle
something that you will know about and
i'm sure you will want to comment on is
tony
abbott i can see that you're wearing
your nhs pride badge
uh i wear mine with pride is what you've
tweeted previously tony abbott who was
the former
prime minister of australia so i'm
suggesting that he may well be
potentially a u.s a uk trade ambassador
he says he feels threatened by
homosexuality he also says elderly
people should have been left to die
naturally from covet
and men are better set to exercise
authority than women
is it the right sort of person to
represent us
well as far as i understand it the
proposal is that
um uh mr abbott supports the uk on trade
policy
which is an area in which he's got a
huge amount of expertise
you know i bow to nobody in my support
for everybody to
uh to to love who they love uh whoever
that
is and and um and and
well as as you know and as we've talked
about uh a lot but i think you know
we want we need to have the best experts
in the world in there working
in their field um and as the former
prime minister of australia
obviously mr abbott's got a huge amount
of experience
even if he's a homophobic misogynist
well i i'm i think that that is uh i
don't think that's
uh true uh i don't i haven't seen him
tell you what he said
i'm sure you don't support some of his
comments he's a homophobe
and he's a misogynist well
uh he's also an expert in uh trade
so one plays off against the other
really is that really what you're saying
health secretary come on
well no what i'm saying is that we need
experts in
different areas and um somebody who's
the former prime minister of australia
is uh obviously an enormous expert in
the uh
in the field of trade it doesn't change
my views
okay so we can forgive his comments
about women
and about letting the elderly die of
kovish 19 and
about his views on um
gay community even though i believe his
sister is gay we can forgive all of that
because he's good at trade
well you know i i'm doing everything in
my power
to prevent a second wave and protect
people from
coronavirus not my question we've spent
eight minutes talking about that i'm
asking you about whether this is a fit
and proper person to represent us
as far as trade is concerned given the
views that he holds
well look i think the best thing to say
is that i am totally focused on the
coronavirus crisis and the
future of the nhs and of social care
that is my
area right i do know that mr abbott
is very good and very experienced in
trade it is clearly
a very important decision that the prime
minister and the trade secretary
are across because we do want experts
absolutely
and people who have huge experience
especially when we're putting together
an area of policy and trade
that frankly has been given over to the
eu for the last um
35 years so there's a good reason there
but but
but you know but i've been obviously
totally focused on
on the health area as you'll entirely
understand i i put it to the former
health secretary yesterday
and i put it to you as well as a forward
thinking 21st century man you might have
a view
on that you obviously don't i know we're
out of time i just wanted to ask you
very quickly about migrants
uh the hostile environment policy uh
clearly isn't working 500 migrants
making the crossing
yesterday almost double what we'd seen
in a single day previously what we're
going to do about that
well there's clearly two things that we
need to do we need to stop the migrants
coming from france and if they
come then we need to have arrangements
to return them france is an extremely
civilized country
i can see absolutely no reason why
anybody
should have to cross from france in an
illegal way and i know the
home secretary is working incredibly
hard on this